John Legend opens up about his baby girl  we're glad to bring Luna here for the  first time Thursday was date night for  John Legend and his wife Chrissy Teigen  at the opening of turned me loose in  off-broadway play John's producing the  new parents look chic and sleek posing  for photos on the red carpet it's great  we're excited to be back in New York  we're glad to bring Luna here for the  first time and it's been a great great  week the couple welcomed their first  child daughter Luna Simone last month  the singer revealed he's already singing  her lullabies had some new stuff from  the next album that I think and when  he's not busy being a dad John is  working his new play is based on the  life of comedian and activist Dick  Gregory he has a life whose story is  worth being told and we want to help get  it out there and we've got the wonderful  Joe Morton portraying him and we feel so  lucky to be part of it